VOICE OVER: Fossils have driven our
understanding of ancient species for centuries
but DNA is changing the game.
ESKE WILLERSLEV: We are walking
around on DNA from the present and,
if we dig down, DNA from the past.
VOICE OVER: Now a team of scientists have
sequenced the oldest DNA ever recovered.
ESKE: Twice the age of what we
previously thought was possible.
VOICE OVER: The DNA is 2-million-years-
old and from it they've reconstructed
a detailed and surprising
picture of an ancient world.
ESKE: We could basically see
this whole ecosystem come to life
and that was amazing, it was just amazing.
VOICE OVER: Eske Willerslev is
a geneticist and palaeontologist
who helped pioneer a technique which
uses ancient DNA to explore the past.
ESKE: If you look around here right, we are
the Zoological Museum in Cambridge, we see
bones all over the place and this has been the
traditional way people were looking at the past.
But I mean fossils are generally very rare.
VOICE OVER: Fossilisation requires very
specific conditions to preserve things
like bone and even then palaeontologists
often have to be lucky to find fossils.
DNA on the other hand is everywhere.
ESKE: Every single cell,
right, in the body contains DNA
and a ground sloth like this or an elephant they
are shedding DNA all the time
to the surroundings, right,
so it's just if I do like this...
DNA will be on this table for me.
VOICE OVER: This is called
environmental DNA or 'e-DNA'.
It's been a core part of
Eske's research for decades
and is now a thriving field in palaeontology
but it wasn't always.
ESKE: I remember it was during
my doctorate and I went into,
you know, my supervisor and I said
to him, well, I think maybe I will
try to test whether DNA from animals and
plants can survive in the soil, right?
Because I was sitting out looking
at the window and I saw leaves fall
down from the trees and a dog
taking a crap on the street.
The question is, what happens to the DNA?
And I said well maybe it's surviving
in the sediments and he laughed at
me and said I've never heard
anything as stupid in my life.
VOICE OVER: Now Eske's research involves
looking for DNA preserved in ancient soils.
ESKE: The DNA molecules are electrically charged
and some of the sediment particles, you know in
the soil, are electrically charged so DNA will
bind to these sediment particles and that will
reduce the chemical degradation rate of the DNA.
VOICE OVER: The colder it is the better the DNA
preservation, so one of the best places to look
for any ancient DNA is ground that's been
continuously frozen — so-called permafrost.
So in 2006 Eske and colleagues headed to
Greenland in search of frozen ancient dirt.
ESKE: It's what we call an Arctic desert.
I mean it's a stony area where you can just
see life is really struggling to survive, and
so are you when you are there to be honest!
VOICE OVER: The team took samples from a
location known as the Kap København Formation.
These were cores of permafrost, the oldest
parts of which dated back two million years.
But when they tried looking for
DNA in 2006 they were out of luck.
ESKE: We tried with those techniques that were
available at the time and we got nothing, right,
I mean — and the general notion at that time was,
well DNA can maximum survive for one
million years. So it wasn't that surprising.
But every time we made improvements
in our DNA extraction methods or our
sequencing abilities we went back to
the Kap København samples and tried,
right, and we failed and we failed and
we failed — until a couple of years ago
and suddenly we got a hit.
VOICE OVER: As the technology developed the team
were able to extract more and more short fragments
of DNA bound to the sediment and then to amplify
these using modern day biomolecular techniques.
ESKE: At that stage it was like, whoa, we
got DNA out that is two million years old,
right. The second whoa was, I think,
when we got the animal DNA out.
VOICE OVER: They were finally able to
piece together the DNA fragments and
build a picture of what this ancient
environment might have looked like.
ESKE: We had a breakthrough and we could basically
see this, this whole ecosystem come to life.
And that was amazing, it was just amazing.
There was mastodons running around, reindeers,
geese, hares, also marine animals like
the horseshoe crab — which suggested
a much warmer environment even in the sea
during that time, which was also surprising.
VOICE OVER: The picture looked very different
from that of modern Greenland. Mastodons,
an ancient relative of elephants,
were a particularly unexpected find.
VOICE OVER: No one had predicted
that mastodon should be around.
It's found in North America,
and Greenland at that time was also an island,
so it was separated from North America just as
today, and therefore people didn't think that
animals like mastodons could get there, right.
But it, well it did, right?
So either it must have been swimming from the
Canadian Islands into Greenland or
potentially walked over the sea ice.
VOICE OVER: Mastodon fossils
have been found in various
sites in North America but never in Greenland
and according to Eske this demonstrates the
benefits of using e-DNA to
study ancient ecosystems.
ESKE: Palaeontology obviously you can do
more than just identify the bone right,
so if you find parts of a skeleton you can
also say things about locomotion for example,
you can say something about whether it was hurt
or damaged you know during life for example.
DNA can't tell you anything about that, but what
DNA can is it gives you information about the
genetic code itself, it gives us the opportunity
to follow evolution in action basically, right,
you can actually see how species are
genetically evolving and changing.
It also gives an opportunity to not only see it
on a species level but a whole ecosystem level.
VOICE OVER: The use of e-DNA is growing
among palaeontologists as techniques
improve and Eske is already thinking
about how to extract even older DNA.
VOICE OVER: I think it's definitely possible to
go back further, I really think so, and I think so
for at least one important reason.
We can see that some of the DNA that is
captured in the sediments we are not really
able at this stage to properly release.
When we become capable of doing that,
and we're working on it obviously,
then I think you will target a whole
new pool of DNA and I think that will
bring us significantly further back.
VOICE OVER: The previous record for
ancient DNA was 1.2 million years
and it belonged to a mammoth
frozen in Siberian permafrost.
So Eske's 2-million-year-old DNA is already a huge
jump — but there may be a limit to
the oldest DNA that can be recovered.
Theoretically the oldest permafrost that
could still exist is 2.6 million years old;
before that it was too warm
for permafrost to form.
But it's not just about finding the oldest DNA.
Getting these kind of techniques
to work in different kinds of
environments is another big challenge.
ESKE: Obviously in Greenland we got the
sample because it's cold — and this is
good for long-term DNA preservation. So
it is really a good place to start if
you want to get DNA that are millions-of-years.
Whether it will also work out in,
you can say, other settings, like
temperate settings for example...
I wouldn't exclude that possibility
at all because temperature,
although it is important, is
not the only determining factor.
VOICE OVER: Of course the study of DNA alone has
its limitations. Without the fossil record we
wouldn't know much about what these animals
actually looked like — but when it comes to
the more recent past eDNA is an exciting
new part of the palaeontologist's toolkit.
ESKE: Environmental DNA is becoming more and
more a tool that people are using in order to
describe communities, right. So I think it will
always be, you can say, a combination of tools.
And I'm sure also we will in the future see
tools that I can't even imagine now to be honest!
VOICE OVER: Even now there are many
more ecosystems yet to be explored
using environmental DNA and perhaps
many more surprises yet to be uncovered.
ESKE: It's great, I mean, this is
why you do science right? It's for
those moments you know where you're
just like, oh my god. I mean it's,
it's just changing the way we looked at things.
and this is the dream of a scientist right.